[Musique]
une assistance aussi officiel que
nombreuses à saluer à paris le 1er mai
pro sur pneus ces nouvelles voitures
roulent sur une piste faite de bois
d'azo b elle même flanqué d'une piste
latéral sur laquelle s'appuie déroule 10
deux horizontales
[Musique]
en cas de crevaison le feu ne s'affaisse
mais il est relayé par une roue
métallique qui lui est jumelée
[Musique]
on sait que le métro parisien transporte
annuellement plus d'un milliard de
voyageurs monsieur 20 ans secrétaire
d'état aux travaux publics accompagné de
monsieur pinet de monsieur chochoy a pu
s'assurer qu'ils voyageraient plus vite
et plus confortablement
[Musique]